saturday night live we'll be back
october 3rd if you're a huge fan of snl
and while jason sedakis and woody
harrison have both played joe biden in
the past
lauren michaels announced yesterday that
jim
carrey will be playing the democratic
presidential nominee this season
yeah jim has an interesting history with
snl he actually was rejected
when he applied to be a cast member on
the show when he was first starting his
career
lauren told vulture how this came about
there was some interest on his part and
then we responded obviously positively
and it came down to discussions about
what the take was he and colin jost had
a bunch of talks he and i as well he
will give the part energy and strength
and hopefully it's funny
obviously woody did biden on the first
show last season did it briefly
jason has done it in the past part of it
also is whoever does it has to basically
relocate to new york
because of the quarantine so there's a
lot of factors involved in that but i'm
thrilled jim's doing it
uh yeah and uh woody actually confirmed
last month to nme that he would not be
back uh
as biden saying i was approached two or
three times but i couldn't do it
so i don't know maybe lauren has moved
on which he probably would be smart to
have
uh have people who are definitely going
to show up because
i don't know i wasn't always going to be
there but i'd be open to doing it again
of course it was fun
of course jim is a very vocal critic of
donald trump he's painted artwork
mocking trump and here's jim poking fun
of them
obamacare it's been going on for a long
time it's been going on from before i
even got elected
and it's a disgrace that it happened and
if you look at what's going on and if
you look at now
all of this information that's being
released and from what
should never be allowed
and you'll be seen
you know what the crime is the crime is
very obvious to everybody all you have
to do is read the newspapers except
yours
wow yeah i think that's that's the
interesting part of this because
i don't know if they really factor
things but you know like this is really
gonna
kiss trump off the fact that jim carrey
someone who's just such a
a vocal critic of him is gonna play the
role but yeah what do you think ira
uh you know i i will always love jim
carrey for
you know liar liar uh eternal sunshine
even a mr poppers penguins moment um
historical yes um this is
it should be fun you know i actually
really have no strong opinion on him
being
biden um i i'm not the biggest fan
of his um anti-trump comedy
because it's just weird um
cool if you're into that um
you know i'll check it out at the moment
but um
it should be fun you know i mean
it'll be interesting seeing him play him
the entire season
you know so um yeah i just i just hope
it is
funny you know um it's interesting to
think about someone playing biden um
and obviously he's been played for years
by
other people um i'm just wondering what
the new
spin on it will be um especially since
biden i feel like part of the comedy in
him is that he's
not that animated you know and uh right
jim carrey is like gumby animated
so um interested in seeing the uh
how it turns out i've always been a huge
fan of jim carrey like you
poppers penguins the whole deal all of
it uh i stopped
i stopped having great interest in jim
carrey because a couple of years ago i
think even
just before he got on his trump comedy
train with the art and everything else
and i am with you the exact same way i
feel about that
uh as you ira but he he he did a few
interviews where he distanced himself
and almost
rewrote his own history where he was
talking about things like ace ventura
and how we all got it wrong and it was
really
this sort of elaborate you know
commentary on
other things and i don't like when
people do that i don't like when they
start sort of
growing out of their old bits and so
they try and rewrite history saying that
it was something
that we all didn't see and we were the
only ones who who didn't get it but i'm
with you and that is that biden
is like part of the things that makes
biden funny
is that he is sort of like that he
stumbles and he sort of has those
grandpa moments
and he loses himself and i don't know
how heavy
they're going to go in on that because
those are the things really with biden
that you can really have a lot of fun
with but they don't necessarily point
biden
in the best light and so jim carrey
knowing his hatred for donald trump
i don't know how hard he will actually
skewer joe biden
and so that's the only reason why i'm
worried about this is i just want the
best comedy
and if the best commie is you know
skewing joe biden
and you know his his sort of you know uh
brain brain clouds
um then that's what i think is the best
way to go i just hope they go there
because to me that's
what would make jim carrey put him at
his best
doing joe biden right i'm paraphrasing a
tweet that i saw yesterday but people
were complaining about the fact that
all snl seems to do now is bring in
celebrities to play
these various real-life figures and the
actual cast members
aren't really getting opportunities
anymore like do you think that's the
thing because yeah i think about like
robert de niro ben stiller
matt damon like they've had all these
huge stars brad brad
right brad pitt but like no one like
none of the cast members really get a
chance to
you know yeah get their shot at these
big roles do you think that's like a
problem for snl or like
i mean it's getting it gets them
attention
you know and especially now you know
with
you know with such a crowded um
you know sandbox but i i do
i do get that criticism you know because
there's a reason why
will farrow like you know like dana
carvey like these people became like
stars on snl by playing the president
you know
and uh kate mckinnon you know uh
tina fey you know and uh if you're just
bringing in a celebrity to do an
impersonation it's like you're not
really utilizing your cast
yeah and if you and if you look through
that if you look through that cast i or
or i can even understand if you bring
back somebody
but even if they're a former cast member
you know like if they told me today
billy billy hater was coming back for
the season bill hader was coming back
for the season to do joe biden
i would be like that's incredible he was
a cast member but i i agree with you on
that and
these i couldn't turn out exactly one of
them anybody
but but you know it was really like like
will ferrell doing you know george w
bush was the highlight you know of of
that sort of
those seasons that he was he was on
there because he was just so
good at it and i'm with you that if
you're gonna you know hire these
talented talented people i think you
give somebody i think you give somebody
a shot
yeah for sure and then you know you
also have my rudolph or probably if they
bring around the place
well then well then what's the point of
that you know
osama says uh biden has terrible timing
as far as his effort the comedy unlike
his chief obama
uh robin says jim carrey is a gifted
comedic actor shut up already
robin wants us to oh wow well nobody
said he wasn't
robin robin
we act we actually complimented
for that man